Let's get back to the map of our models.
We've so far built three different models and used several validation methods,
including ROC curves, to choose the model that performs best.
We could end our investigation here.
However, we can ask a further question.
Will changing the classes change the model?
Let's investigate this a little bit further.
To investigate this question a little bit further,
we come back to our original point where we started building our models.
To continue that investigation,
we'll now build new classifiers by redefining the classes.
Then we'll use different validation metrics and choose a new model.
At this point, we have our entire map of our model-building and
validation process.
Let's investigate this end a little bit more to see what metrics we
can use to validate models with our new classes.
We're back to the precision, recall and F-Score video 28.
The sensitivity and specificity of a classifier are symmetric
measurements in the sense that the changes in false positives or
false negatives do not affect the sensitivity or specificity respectively.
Thus in our example we had two instances of classes, B and F.
And we decided, thus in our example,
we had two classes B and F and we classified between those two.
Now we re-ask the question to see if we
can choose between two classes that are asymmetric.
In our new problem, we have slightly redefined the problem.
We want to ask if something belongs to Class G or not Class G.
This is a one versus all classifier.
We're going to look at some metrics called precision, recall and
F-score, that helps us in validating classification problems and
models based on these kinds of classifiers.
The difference being, the instances for Class G are a lot less
than the instances for not Class G in the data.
Let's get back to our Python notebook and
see how we can build these models first.
In this piece of code, we are starting to classify person1 vs all.
We call that ova_person, or
One Versus All person, and we choose G as that class.
We now divide up the events such that we have G and not g as the two classes.
Let's run this piece of code first.
In the previous piece of code, we have setup the one versus all data.
Let's look at what the y values are between then this is 220 to 230.
Run this piece of code now.
You see the ten values are Fs and Gs, with the last four values being G.
Now let's see how this looks when we have the one versus all.
Let's see how this looks for the one versus all data.
Run this line of code.
Notice, all the labels that are not G are labelled as false.
All the labels that are G are labelled as true.
Running the next line of code gives you the total number of false and
true in each of the training and the test samples.
We are now ready to build our models.
Run this line of code that initializes the models and
trains with x_train and y_train with the one verses all model.
Now that we have built our one verses all models,
let's try to print our accuracy, or score, for each of these models.
Running this line gives us the accuracy for each of the LogisticRegression,
RandomForest, and Support Vector Classifier models.
Note, this time the classes are quite different than what we had before.
Now we will define a few more metrics that are useful for
selecting between these kind of classification models.
We are now going to look at the definitions of precision, recall and
f score and come back and calculate these for the model we just built.